we're learning new details about the
night a former Dallas police officer
shot and killed her neighbor in his home
as her murder trial continues amber
Geiger claims she thought she was in her
own apartment and both of John was a
burglar
Omar Villafranca is at the courthouse in
Dallas Omar what did prosecutors reveal
good morning prosecutors say that at the
time of the shooting amber Geiger was
preoccupied talking and texting with a
partner who she was romantically
involved with and the jury got a preview
of some of those sexually explicit
messages she shoots twice at the start
of amber Geiger's trial prosecutors
argued the former Dallas police officer
missed several opportunities to avoid
the deadly confrontation with her
neighbor 26-year old both am John
according to prosecutors one of those
errors was a romantic conversation
Geiger was carrying on with her patrol
partner in the minutes before the
shooting Geiger and fellow officer
Martin Rivera allegedly had a phone call
and exchanged sexually explicit messages
Rivera took the witness stand Monday and
I really don't remember a whole lot else
about the conversation in the opening
statement the defense dismissed the
prosecution's argument that Geiger
should have realized she was on the
wrong floor is this extremely obvious
bright red floor mat to say that she was
aware there was a red doormat knowingly
because she wanted to go in to 1478 and
shoot this man it's preposterous Jean
was from st. Lucia his parents arrived
in Texas and spoke exclusively to us
before the start of the trial they say
they want Geiger to be honest about what
she was thinking before she shot and
killed their son
I just want kind of a finality to all of
this the best thing she can do is to go
clean
the defense is arguing that jean was
approaching Geiger before she shot him
but the prosecution says he barely had
any time to stand up we're gonna have to
see what the physical evidence says as
for the jurors they will be sequestered
the whole trial no cell phones no
computers and this trial is expected to
last about two weeks Tony a lot of
interesting new details there Omar thank
you very much